le rendez vous du sport chaque lundi
dans le 7 8 aux alentours de 18h15 18h20
si vous nous suivez en direct nous
sommes encore ensemble jusqu'à 19h
anthony ce soir trois invités sur ce
plat très il ya du beau monde ce soir
tout d'abord patrick sino qui va nous
faire découvrir le krav maga vous êtes
le directeur de l'association
d'elancourt
on sera revenu exactement et attention
on ne rigole pas riche je sors un single
que sinon je ne serais pas passer ça va
être compliqué avoue côté jean-françois
remili le vice-président de
du club de triathlon de saint quentin en
yvelines qui a fait une très très bonne
saison en élite cette année on reviendra
ou reviendra sur ce beau parcours et on
vient on ira à la rencontre de vos deux
athlètes tout à l'heure et à côté de moi
claude de grêle bonsoir à vous président
du club de plongée de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines c'était à qui
on va revenir évident avec vous sur l'a7
belle histoire ses trente années puisque
vous fêtez vos trente ans c'est trio
gagnant de la page au sport ce soir il
voit c'est le trio gagnant exactement on
débute par ce fameux krav maga moyens
vous savez ce que c'est le krav maga
wilfried tout à fait je voulais c'est
pas ça c'est votre page
je voudrais pas voler la vedette on va
demander un peu plus de précisions
justement à patrick qu'est ce que c'est
que le krav maga alors le krav maga
c'est une méthode d'autodéfense
essentiellement ça peut être aussi un
sport de combat
issu du close combat de l'armée
israélienne est alors du coup c'est une
technique pour apprendre à juste à se
défendre en fait c'est ça
essentiellement c'est à dire qu'au
départ le close combat c'est c'est pas
juste pour apprendre à défendre c'est
aussi pour apprendre à faire du mal mais
la droite
le fait de l'avoir institué pour le
public c'est un rendu vraiment
d'autodéfense est alors en quoi ça
consiste là on va justement des images
de l'entraînement la semaine dernière en
quoi ça consiste c'est essayer de faire
tomber l'autre de profiter de ces gestes
vraiment de se sortir de toutes les
situations difficiles
voilà c'était plutôt la dernière
solution c'est à dire c'est c'est un art
martial enfin aussi ça peut être un art
martial dans le sens où on utilise les
arbres et on doit pouvoir se sortir de
n'importe quelle situation
donc le principe c'est à partir de
gestes de gestes simples rapides de
pouvoir neutraliser un adversaire le
plus rapidement possible sans faire trop
de dégâts bien sûr mais aussi pour
sortir intact de la situation de ses
possibilités
et alors le krav maga est ce qu'on peut
en faire à n'importe quel âge à 0 un
jeune peut en faire par exemple en
dessous de 16 ans alors normalement non
mais bientôt ça va être ça va être
institué c'est dieu on a une méthode
pédagogique pour les moins de 16 ans qui
vient d'israël
mais en france on n'a pas encore on n'a
pas encore testé ça va venir mais à
partir de 16 ans sur elle en cours on
peut faire du krav maga en dessous non
ça veut dire quoi c'est trop violent
pour les jeunes
oui c'est à dire qu'en fait on de la
méthode que qu'on enseigne est assez
radical et l'ancien pour des adultes
il faut quand même une certaine maturité
on estime jeumont des enfants sur 16 ans
ça pour présenter de risque
éventuellement s'il l'utilisé mais dans
les arts martiaux on explique aux gens
ça fait partie du cours que ce soit le
judo ou autres noms qu'il faut pas
l'utiliser en dehors des tatamis qu'il
faut faire très attention vous le fait
aussi
ah oui bien sûr mais là comme ces deux
situations que c'est une méthode
d'autodéfense
forcément on à la légitime défense avec
nous et donc on doit utiliser uniquement
dans ce cadre là et vous expliquez bien
aux jeunes par exemple aux jeunes parce
qu'à 16 ans à rasteau jeunes qui
viennent vous voir qu'il faut pas
s'amuser à faire n'importe quoi il est
vrai que l'amour tout à fait et alors ce
qu'on a sur les parents travaillent
ensemble à la fin histoire en disant je
veux faire du gras exactement mais c'est
quelque chose qu'on peut utiliser au
quotidien est ce qu'il ya des
retranscriptions justement dans les
gestes
oui alors justement le fait d'utiliser
déjà des gestes les plus simples c'est
parce qu'on fait parce qu'on a
l'habitude de faire dans notre vie
quotidienne
et puis on utilise beaucoup envient
d'extraits c'est à dire que en krav maga
s'il y a quelque chose qui arrive de ma
gauche
je vais pas utiliser ma main droite pour
couvrir je vais utiliser ma main gauche
elle pourra si elle arrive et les
familles à risque
le fait d'utiliser cette ambidextrie ce
sacre est une espèce de symétrie
gestuelle qui vous aide dans la journée
ben des fois éviter le faux geste
chercher ça ici de prendre plutôt ex est
malade c'est le passé comme ça voilà
donc même dans le quotidien c'est de
chercher toujours le trajet le plus
rapide la simplicité
ça se retranscrit en fait dans notre vie
quotidienne tout à fait et alors
justement on peut progresser rapidement
les gens qui vivent ce fait pris vite à
saisir les techniques de sa fait pour ça
de méthode a été justement fait pour
remettre au feu des combattants le afin
d'y arriver le plus rapidement possible
les former en quelques mois et pour
qu'il soit vraiment efficace
et alors dans cette période un peu on
parle souvent des vols à la tire
mon distributeur de billets les jeunes
femmes par exemple les personnes un peu
âgées viennent nous voir ils vous disent
voilà j'ai envie de savoir me défendre
contre ça malheureusement mais c'est la
clientèle qu'on peut avoir en ce moment
qui est lié à la recrudescence de la
violence et des activités un peu on va
dire un petit peu malhonnête il peut y
avoir en tournée mais derrière ça risque
pas d'entraîner peut-être encore plus de
violence parce que c'est pas forcément
le comportement qu'on comprenne de se
défendre tout de suite c'est plutôt de
donner son sac et oui mais non mais nous
on va pas on va pas vous dire non à les
consacrer puis voilà faut y aller non
mais après si on regarde d'attac
voilà ce que l'intégrité physique on
protège donc si jamais il ya une attaque
s'il n'y a pas de cette attaque sur
l'intégrité physique
on espère maintenant si jamais quelqu'un
vous fermez forcément la presse il faut
pour les trois cadres c'est la défense
merci beaucoup patrick si nous devions
nous faire découvrir cette technique de
combat le krav maga
on suivra vos activités tout au long de
la saison au cours des événements merci
beaucoup